what's going on guys this is rob and i'm
getting ready to go into work here in a
minute before i went into work there's a
couple things we need to go over some
things we need to talk about some
updates on this channel on like the
future of what we're going to do with
this youtube channel because we are
pressed for time the 2015 summer event
is coming very very fast much faster
than I initially thought 2015 is coming
very quickly and in all honesty December
is we're what like six or seven days and
December already like a week into it so
we've got a lot of stuff that we have to
cover my initial intention was to do
like this great big build-up like this
huge build up to the age of apocalypse
that's not going to happen we don't have
time for that you know plus like the
views in those videos are down and I
think there's only like a handful of you
guys really want to see it they really
care about like the build up to the age
of apocalypse why do you guys just want
the Age of Apocalypse you just want to
know what the hell was going on and how
it was that apocalypse came to too I
guess create this alternate reality or
how the alternate reality came into
existence is the hands of Legion a
little Vallois whatever so anyway so
here's what we're going to do after
Deadpool kills the marvel universe we're
going to do infinity war after infinity
war we're going to do the age of
apocalypse now once the adriel pops is
finished we're going to try to have that
done by the beginning of january and the
reason why is because of two things 1
i'm going to be doing this full time in
january i'm going to be like my last day
at this job is december 29th the other
reason is because me and Vinny are going
to try to get into the house of m at the
beginning of January which means that
I've got to do the Avengers disassembled
before we actually get into the house of
them now the Avengers disassembled isn't
like a massive event it's not I mean in
terms of like who's involved is pretty
big but it's not like stretched out it's
not like a long-running event it's
relatively short and so after that we'll
do House of M after House of M is over
we'll do Secret Invasion after secret
invasion is over then we're going to
jump past the age of Ultron and original
sin because we already did that and
we're going to do the incursions the New
Avengers and the incursions and all that
stuff because what you have is basically
this great big huge domino effect you
have it all pretty much started with the
house of em when they meet and slosh
their powers the mutants lose their
powers and Eaton's gain their powers
back you have the ramifications you have
all that kind of stuff whatever
you have age of Ultron with Wolverine
where he breaks time and because will
rain did what he did in age of Ultron
everything after that the incursions and
all that stuff is set into motion so
we've got a lot of things like the whole
incursions things is what leads up to
the the 2015 summer event with all these
different universes coming together and
all this kind of stuff taking place so
yeah we've got a lot of stuff that we
have to go over and we just don't have
enough time to do everything that I'd
love to do so so yeah also let me know
how you guys feel about having like a
relatively consistent Deadpool thing
like like once every two months we'll do
like a Deadpool story or something like
that like we'll do like Merc with a
mouth there was something wrong so let
me know you guys think and I will catch
you guys later peace